(soft music)
(breathes heavily)
(page turns)
(soft music)
(engine whirs)
(upbeat music)
(door opens)
- I know you haven't been
sleeping in your room,
so, where, exactly, have you
been spending your nights?
- Yeah, feel free to help out too Joey.
- Actually, I was gonna head
into town for a little bit,
and take some pictures
before we hit the road.
Remember, like we said we would?
You're gonna be okay here?
- I think I'll be fine, Joey.
(upbeat music)
- [Male Narrator] And a
boy looked out his window,
at the girl next door.
(upbeat music)
(breathes heavily)
- Don't get me wrong, I
love a good floor show,
but, if this a response
to Jughead threatening
your masculinity or whatever.
- I'm just getting my daily workout in.
(soft music)
(water runs)
- Thought you might want some company.
(soft music)
(upbeat music)
- No please, no don't!
(fire smolders)
Ah!
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Archie, Archie.
(shoes tapping)
(body slams)
- Archie!
- Gonna need some strong
allies I can trust.
(door opens)
Archie Andrews, what a surprise.
- I heard you're trying to buy Riverdale.
You gotta step up and lead the Bulldogs.
- I'm already captain bro.
- Yeah, I'm not talking
about on the field.
I need you to work with Jughead,
to keep the peace between the
Serpents and the Bulldogs.
No more circles, red, dark or otherwise.
- Done.
- Archie!
(soft music)
Are you listening to me?
- Yeah.
- We have to burn all of our clothes,
including Jughead's baby.
- You think you can attack
us from the shadows,
but Riverdale, is a lot stronger than you,
and we're not afraid.
(water runs)
(upbeat music)
(punching bag jingles)
(soft music)
(crowd applauds)